I just wanted to get the [__] out of
there did you really was in the belly
room no no we we at The Improv no oh I
switched it at the Improv you switched
at The Improv I don't think I have the
power to do it there well it definitely
got switched we were
up wow so let me okay so about the
forest then okay yeah let's talk about
the forest we wanted you up we want you
up there and ask Yannis this yeah I was
in New York the last time I was in New
York I called y said I go I'm ready to
go to the
forest you guys were not available for
it uh well that's probably sched the
forest is closed the forest no cuz we
want to take you to restaurants up there
so you know how much better being out of
New York City is because New York City
is the [__] worst I think wow and
it's the worst in terms of food there's
no way oh no no no no food New York City
food's incredible we have great but I'm
just saying up there but you're saying
you're going take me a restaurant in the
woods that's going to be better than New
York City I your [__] mind we have
three restaurants up there that are as
good wow wow so we'll sit down and D
hang out you'll see some deer and [__]
you know you'll see some Wildlife we're
up there an hour away
beautiful uh but how hard is it you're
in the woods right how hard is it to get
in the city and I'm not dude like David
Letterman's my neighbor I'm not in the
wood I almost hit him in a car by the
way he jogs and I almost hit him oh
really yeah we don't we don't have I
know D could you imagine I [__]
honked I you mother and it looked and it
was just him with his [__] beard you
know what I imagine the movie remember
the scene in signs yes yes you remember
signs yeah they kept flashing back to
when to the wife to the pinned against
the pinned against and she gets things
out like she's got to sit tell someone
to swing or whatever what if you had
that with David Letter oh you know what
he would think your career's over I
would just
go top 10 reasons why you shouldn't kill
[__] David Letterman in your
car a top 10 that's top 10
reasons let's I I do I do Wonder like is
your career over when you run um David
Letterman if I hit him with the car and
he lived it would probably be good um
but if I hit him with the car and he
died dude I can't be like hey watch my
Netflix speci that would be well
actually my Netflix special would
probably take off if yeah I think so too
yeah but then but I can't what am i g to
do after that though you have to do
David lman material like you have to
talk about it yeah I think I think if he
died is less than if he lived yeah
because when he lived he could talk
about it exactly not maybe not
oh I
see yeah I see maybe not you know he
gets like you know what I mean yeah
traumatic TBI yeah yeah wow yeah yeah
yeah no when we say Woods we're just in
a nice country neighborhood an hour from
the city and it's beautiful well you
talk because the pitch that you had
before though was that there's deer so
in my mind it's like I don't see deer
wait we have deer here at all the oh my
God at all the golf courses right by um
where I hike where the Vermont Canyon
tennis courts are there's deer coyote um
everything okay let me just say
something to you all right it's a middle
of La Bobby okay I want to say something
I'm just saying from my own experience
right living in La for 25 [__] years
I've never seen a [__] you don't
leave the house it's fine but here's the
thing me and we get the deer like me and
Yannis were in my backyard a deer walked
up to us walked up to us wow and we
started feeding it and we started
feeding it Grand I started feeding
graham crackers and Doritos and [__] I'm
not take it yeah and there's nothing
funnier than when you hear a deer crunch
a
Dorito really I swear to God and but
then the daughter came because they're
all because the you'll never see a buck
you'll never see the males the males
know it's hunting they're not there but
the mothers and The Young and the young
the phon they come up and when they find
out they're just they all come and
they're like no is it is it legal to
kill
them if it's on if you had a shotgun
right there if it's on my property and I
had a right
I don't know if I would get in trouble
if it was being aggressive and I shot it
or if it was walking towards me but
you're not supposed to shoot them yeah
so so you fed at Doritos the deer yeah
we fed at Doritos we feeded stuff but
Yannis was a Brooklyn kid for like 40
years and then he moved he moved up
because of me because him and his
girlfriend would visit us uh you guys
are close we're very close so Giannis
and I like when I went through dark
times when he goes through dark times we
kind of had this just we'd always see
each other at the stand we would do sets
together and I'd be like you got to
bring bring her up to the country and he
would and I didn't think she's going to
come cuz she's a Long Island Long Island
people don't leave Long Island people
are like they stay in Long Island it's
like it's they really you're just like
never leaving but she like fell in love
with it up there so they moved up there
but he never saw like when people from
the city come over and see like five
deer five feet from them it's like they
s in a UFO they're like they just I had
this I had this Puerto Rican kid uh this
Dominican kid you know Vladimir kamano
he's a he's a comic he's he Russian too
he's Dominican no his father named him
that because of something like that
actually because of some [__] he
named him Vladimir but his name is
Vladimir commo funny comic he's always
at the he's always at the stand and I go
he's Dominican and I go come up and he
saw a deer in my backyard and it's Domin
from he's from the Bron he's Dominican
from the Bronx and he's looking at a
deer I swear to God he's gone he's going
you
serious yo yo you serious you serious
right now you serious right now like he
so like aliens came because when people
from the city see that [__] they they're
not br is Brooklyn 4 years imagine if
you had a koala on a tree too serious
you [__] serious that only in
Australia are you serious I got a
kangaroo in my backyard what if it was
like you know all these like animals are
popping out of the bushes like a mircat
you serious are you Ser Ser right now
that would be amazing speaking of UFOs
like